son prénom sepang faille son nom de
famille lee il est professeur de
géographie économique aux hec à montréal
il vit à montréal avec son épouse et
leurs deux enfants depuis trois ans
durant lesquels il a appris le français
pong faille représente la troisième
génération d'une famille chinoise qui a
vécu des bouleversements spectaculaire
depuis le début du régime communiste il
ya 70 ans promeut la camara leurs rêves
et aide d'avoir une rive table et de
survivre pour mes parents c'est de
manger suffisamment et aussi si il y à
des moyens peut-être pour notre enfant
c'est bien d'avoir à une bonne éducation
pointe foyer né en 1984 dans le nord-est
de la chine dans la province du shandong
cette péninsule qui fait face à la corée
c'est la province de naissance de
confucius une de ses grandes villes
abritent la fameuse brasserie shing tao
il vient d'un tout petit village gène
charge wang qun d'à peine 200 habitants
le voici à l'école primaire du village
lorsque mao tsé toung prend le pouvoir
en 1949 ses grands parents ont une
dizaine d'années mahomet un terme à
quarante ans de guerre civile
il instaure un régime de type soviétique
qui collectivise les productions
agricoles et industrielles c'est la paix
mais la population reste toujours aussi
pauvre en 1958 mao exige que tous les
chinois y compris les agriculteurs se
consacre à la production d'acier c'est
le grand bond en avant
tout doit être fondus dans des hauts
fourneaux pour produire de l'acier qui
s'avérera de trop mauvaise qualité pour
être utilisés
résultat la production de nourriture
s'effondre dans tout le pays il n'avait
pas là il marche tôt même les dates le
ferait et c'est la famine fera quelque
45 millions de morts on rapporte des cas
de cannibalisme les campagnes ne
connaîtront pas vraiment les purges de
la révolution culturelle de 1966 à 1969
qui décime la population des villes la
nouvelle délégation chinoise arrivée à
new york vit à paris lorsque la chine
entre nations unies et se rapproche du
l'occident elle est encore un des pays
les plus pauvres du monde
les conditions de vie se sont quand même
amélioré la mortalité infantile a chuté
l'espérance de vie a doublé
l'enseignement primaire et généralisé
l'analphabétisme a reculé
le culte de la personnalité du grand
timonier durera jusqu'à sa mort en 1976
et pour vos grands parents la mort de
mao qu'est ce que c'était
catastophe as commencé le 10 e et puis
disons l'écran fiance sur lui pour tous
les choses sous l'impulsion de deng
xiaoping à partir de 1979
les dirigeants chinois lance des
réformes pour accélérer la modernisation
économique du pays l'économie la société
sont profondément transformé la terre
est rendu aux paysans les marchés
deviennent libres toutes les productions
augmente
la chine commence à exporter massivement
les parents de pente faille auront deux
enfants un fils et une fille
la politique de l'enfant unique pour
réduire une natalité galopante ne
s'applique pas dans les campagnes
cette partie de la province de shandong
produit essentiellement des pommes
depuis toujours la famille de pong
faille cultive dépoli clavier était
difficile parce qu'elle a pris devant
était très bas et puis après 90
la prérentrée ce sont de belles pommes
de type fugee exporté partout en chine
mais aussi en corée en russie la chine
et de nos jours le premier exportateur
mondial de pommes la vie de famille
s'améliore petit à petit surtout dans
les années 90 réfrigérateur et téléphone
en 1995 il enrage et elle est acteur
plus tard les motocycles est aussi plus
tard les ordinateurs cette formule
résume la stratégie de dingue pour la
survie du parti communiste réformes
économiques
oui en vitesse réformes politiques
jamais
je ne paysans sans emploi quittent leur
campagne pour tenter leur chance en
ville les désirs de démocratie ont été
réprimées dans le sang sur la place
tienanmen en 1989
l'adhésion en 2001 de la chine à l'om
c'est l'organisation mondiale du
commerce lui ouvre des marchés les
investisseurs étrangers la courtise la
chine et l' usine
le bazar de la planète et elle
s'enrichit elle a les moyens de se
lancer dans des projets pharaoniques
la croissance annuelle à shanghai frise
les 15%
c'est maintenant le plus gros chantier
de construction au monde avec les jeux
olympiques de 2008 c'est la consécration
la preuve est faite que la chine devient
puissances mondiales de premier rang de
nombreux partenariats étrangers lui ont
donné accès de la technologie de pointe
l'élève a dépassé les m trente mille
kilomètres de tgv alors qu'il n'y en a
pas un seul dans toutes les amériques
airbus et bombardier lui en donner les
bases de son premier jet commercial
comac c919 et anglais en marché le
premier drone taxis du monde et huawei
est un leader mondial dans la téléphonie
5 g la première génération d
entrepreneurs ils ont les moyens et la
royale à des enfants à l'étrangère ou
dans la meilleure ligne c'était pour
bien être étudiée et puis maintenant les
effets arrive donc fait y obtient son
diplôme de l'université de pékin en 2011
le voici avec ses parents il veut
continuer sa formation à l'étranger et
il pense au canada
[Musique]
le développement effréné de la chine a
des inconvénients sérieux aujourd'hui le
jan qui charrie aussi dans ses eaux
la maladie et la mort c'est le visage
caché la terrible rançon du miracle
économique chinois la chine s'est
attaqué sérieusement à la pollution
elles devront aussi relever le niveau de
vie des paysans qui restent dans les
campagnes alors que les
multimilliardaires sont de plus en plus
nombreux autre problème social le
vieillissement de la population la chine
se projette de plus en plus à l'étranger
non seulement elle ans chez elle entre
hong kong et la chine continentale un
pont de 55 km mais elle lance aussi au
mozambique dans les balkans avec sa
nouvelle route de la soie
l'initiative route et ceinture la chine
investit prête et donne de l'argent
partout dangereux tout ça est perçue
souvent comme une menace
[Musique]
quand la chine s'éveillera le monde
tremblera aurait dit napoléon il ya 200
ans elle s'est éveillée et comment
maintenant le monde a les yeux rivés sur
hong kong et les manifestations en
faveur de la démocratie
bientôt ils le seront sur taïwan pour
les mêmes raisons la chine une menace il
a beaucoup d'acteurs qui va être ok
ouailles en français la future beaucoup
d'incertitudes
oui et bien mais peut-être maintenant il
a plu dans cette étude plus cette
attitude
la puissance économique de la chine
n'est plus à démontrer pour cet
anniversaire
shi jean ping a choisi de faire étalage
de sa puissance militaire et de ses
armes dernier cri
faut-il s'en inquiéter
[Musique]